The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Good
morning, everyone.
Today, we're going to
talk about boosting.
Boosting is pretty awesome,
and it's not as hard
as it might seem.
It's actually pretty easy,
as long as you do it right.
So let's take a look at
this boosting problem.
Just like with ID
trees, you may have
noticed there's the ID tree
problem where there's a graph,
and all of the tests are x and
y-axis tests on that graph.
And then there's
the ID tree problem
where there are a lot of
crazy different classifiers
about characteristics
that are discrete.
And then all of the sort of
ID tree stumps, if you will,
are built out of those
discrete qualities.
This is an example
of a boosting problem
of the second type with a
bunch of discrete qualities,
like evil, emo,
transforms, sparkly.
And it has an numerical quality
number of romantic interests.
So it's one of
basically the two kinds
of boosting problems
that you might see.
And now, there is the
two-axis Cartesian problem.
A good example of
that is the hours
of sleep versus coffee problem,
which I, for one, am planning
on doing in tutorial on Monday
so that you guys sort of get
a sense of both
types of problems.
This one looks big.
I think it looks-- I mean,
it has ten different vampires
or non-vampires to classify.
It has a whole bunch of
possible classifiers.
But if you do it right,
you can do it fast.
So here's the prompt
for the problem.
Let's see.
After graduating
MIT, you get a job
working for Van
Helsing and Sommers,
a famous vampire-hunting
consulting agency.
Gabriel Van Helsing,
one of the two founders,
once attended several
6.034 lectures as a guest,
and he remembers
Professor Winston's
vampire identification
tree lecture.
He assigns you the
task of creating
a superior classifier
for vampires
by using boosting on
the following data.
So we've got the
ID number, which
we can use to just write
things out in shorthand.
We've got the name of several
vampires and non-vampires.
Then you see whether
they're a vampire or not.
That's whether
their classification
is a plus or minus for
the quality of vampire.
After that, there's a
bunch of possible ways
to classify whether
they're a vampire or not.
There's whether or not
they're evil, whether or not
they're emo, whether
or not they transform,
and whether or not
they're sparkly, as well
as the number of romantic
interests that they have.
So for instance,
on the one hand,
you have Dracula, who's
evil, but he's not emo.
He can transform into a
bat or a cloud of mist.
He does not sparkle, and he
has five romantic interests--
those three vampire chicks
at the beginning, Wilhelmina
Murray, and Lucy Westenra.
So on the other hand,
you have Squall Leonhart,
who's the protagonist of Final
Fantasy VII, is extremely emo
and doesn't have any of
the other characteristics.
And he's not a vampire.
However, he's a
nice counterexample
for a possible rule
that all emo people
are vampires because
he's very, very emo,
and he's not a vampire.
So how will we go about tackling
this problem with boosting?
Well, there's a whole bunch
of different classifiers.
And if you think
this is all of them--
like evil, emo,
transforms, sparkly.
romantics interests, and
true-- it's actually only half
of them.
The other half are
the opposite versions,
but we'll ignore them for now.
So if you look at
these, you can probably
figure out what they
mean-- evil equals
yes means vampire is
what we're saying here--
except maybe true.
You might be saying, why is
there one that just says true?
The one that just says true says
that everybody is a vampire.
You might think, oh, that sucks.
But it's not that bad since
seven of the 10 samples
are vampires.
The key, crucial
thing about boosting
is that for any
possible classifier,
like classifying on the evil
dimension-- which actually
sounds like some
kind of weird place
that you'd go in a comic book.
But classifying on the
emo dimension or whatever,
as long as it's not a
50-50 split of the data,
you're guaranteed
to be able to use it
in some way for boosting.
If there is a 50-50 split,
it's like flipping a coin,
so it's useless.
Because if you had
some other thing,
like gender equals
male or female--
and let's say that was 50-50.
It's not.
But let's say it was
50-50 between vampire
and non-vampire-- it's
a useless classifier
because it would be just
the same as flipping a coin.
You'd get no information.
Now, you might
say, wait a minute.
What about classifiers
that get worse than 50-50?
What about them?
Might not they be even worse
than a 50-50 classifier?
I claim a classifier
that gets less than 50-50
is still better than
a classifier that
gets exactly a 50-50 split.
Is there a question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
In the ID tree example, somebody
said you used 50-50 classifiers
and played around.
And after you already
produced the elements per set,
then you only used 50-50
classifiers [INAUDIBLE]
per set.
PROFESSOR: So the question
is, in the ID tree example,
you might use 50-50
classifiers in later rounds
if, for instance, there's
a 50-50 classifier
except for that most of
the things off of that side
have been already removed.
Let's say there's
20 data points,
and there's a classifier
that splits it 10 and 10.
And it gets half plus
half minus on both sides.
But all the pluses
from the right side
have been removed by
some other classifier.
You might use it.
That's true.
But in boosting, you
will never use something
that's a 50-50 classifier.
You never use something that
has exactly a 50-50 chance
of being correct.
Because if it has a 50-50 chance
of being correct, it's useless.
And if it has a 50-50
chance of-- no, sorry.
Let me specify again.
You'll never use
something that has
a 50-50 chance of giving you the
right answer given the weights.
That's very, very important.
And that may be what your
question was getting at.
As I'm about to show you
and as Patrick told you
in the lecture, in later
rounds of boosting,
you change the weights of
each of the 10 data points.
At first, you start with
all weights being 1/10.
The weights have add up to 1.
In this case, you
never, ever choose
a classifier that gets five
of them right and five of them
wrong.
In the later rounds,
you'll never, ever
choose a classifier that
gets half of the weight
wrong-- exactly half
of the weight wrong.
But half of the weight may not
be half of the data points.
So it's possible to
choose a classifier that
gets half of the data
points wrong if it doesn't
get half of the weight wrong.
And that's similar to an
ID tree when you've already
gotten things right before.
Because you'll see that
the weight is going to go
to the ones you got wrong.
So I'm not saying that
you should throw out
right away anything that gets
five of the points wrong.
Hell, you shouldn't even throw
out right away something that
gets seven of the points wrong.
It's possible-- possible-- that
you can get seven of the points
wrong, or getting less
than half of the weight
wrong if those other three
points are really, really
annoying to get right.
And we'll see that later on.
But for insight, at
every step along the way,
we're willing to choose
any classifier that
doesn't get 50-50.
However, we want to choose
the classifier that gets
the most of the weight right.
By most of the
weight, at first, we
mean most of the points right.
Later, we will mean exactly what
I said-- most of the weight.
And if you don't understand
that, it's sometimes
hard to get it right
away when Patrick just
lectures through it,
introduces a new concept.
If you don't
understand that, you'll
see what I mean when we
go through, all right?
So my point I was making
before is, what about things
that get less than half
of the weight right?
Well, those are always OK
because you can just flip them
around, use their inverse,
and that gets more than half
of the weight right.
It's sort of like--
yeah, it's sort
of like my girlfriend
always tells me
that she is more than 50% likely
to choose the wrong direction
when you're trying to go
between two places, which
I'm kind of skeptical of.
But I said, if
that's really true,
then we can just go wherever
you didn't say to go,
and we'll be more likely
to go the right way.
So you're actually really
good at finding the place
that we want to go.
And then she's like,
no, that won't work.
Because then I'll know that
you're going to do that,
and I'll double
say the wrong way.
And then you'll go
the wrong way again.
But that not withstanding,
you can see you
can apply the same
concept to boosting.
And that's why
underneath of this,
I have all the opposite
versions of all these tests.
So what should we be doing
to solve this problem more
quickly?
First, let's figure out which
data points are misclassified
by each of these classifiers.
In other words, if we say all
the evil things are vampires
and all the non-evil
things are not vampires,
what do we get wrong?
And if we do that
for every classifier,
then that'll make
it faster later on.
Because later on, we're going
to go through classifiers,
and we're going to have to add
up the ones they got wrong.
So this chart over here is
going to be extremely useful.
And on the test that
this appeared in,
they even made you fill it
in to help yourself out.
So let's see.
If we said that all the
evil equals yes are vampires
and all the evil equals
no are not vampires,
then-- I'll do the
first one for you.
So we get all of
the non-vampires
correct because they
are all evil equals no.
But unfortunately, we get Angel,
Edward Cullen, Saya Otonashi,
and Lestat de Lioncourt wrong
because they are vampires,
and they're evil equals no.
Apparently, Lestat is iffy.
But I never read those books,
and the Wikipedia article
said that in the end,
he wasn't that evil.
So there we go.
Evil equals yes
misclassifies 2, 3, 4, and 5.
All right, so let's
try emo equals yes.
I'll have someone else do it.
So let's see if you guys got it.
So if we say that all the
emo people are vampires
and all the non-emo
people are not vampires,
what do we get wrong?
AUDIENCE: 1, 6, 7, 9.
PROFESSOR: 1, 6, 7, 9-- that's
exactly right, and fast.
Good.
We get 1, 6, 7, and 9 wrong.
1, 6, and 7 are wrong
because they are not emo,
but they're vampires.
9 is wrong because Squall is
emo, and he is not a vampire.
Good.
OK, what if we said that exactly
the transforming characters are
vampires and the ones that do
not transform are not vampires?
Which ones will we get wrong?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Transforms
is the next one over.
AUDIENCE: All of the
ones [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So
which ones would we
get wrong if we said that said
transforms yes were vampires
and transforms no
were not vampires?
AUDIENCE: We'd get 8 wrong.
PROFESSOR: We'd
definitely 8 wrong
because she's not a vampire.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, no.
It's actually on there.
AUDIENCE: And 3 and 4
we'd also get wrong.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
AUDIENCE: As well as 5.
PROFESSOR: Yes, exactly.
OK.
Oh, man.
You didn't see the chart.
You were just like, hmmm.
You saw the left.
You just said, hm,
which one of these
are the transforming characters?
OK, that's pretty hardcore.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER].
PROFESSOR: But yeah,
3, 4, 5, and 8.
No, no, it's definitely
given to you.
That would be like
the worst test
ever for international students.
Ah, if you don't know these
ten characters as vampires,
you lose.
All right, so what
about that sparkly
equals yes is a vampire,
and if it's not sparkly,
it's not a vampire?
This is guaranteed
not to go well.
What do you think it's
going to get wrong?
AUDIENCE: For sparkly?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, sparkly equals
yes are the only vampires.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] wrong.
Angel's going to be wrong.
Saya-- so 1, 2,
4, 5, 6, 7, and 8.
PROFESSOR: And 8--
yes, that's right.
It gets 1, 2, 4, 5,
6, 7, and 8 wrong.
That's pretty awful.
But dammit, it gets
Edward Cullen right.
And he's hard to get
correct due to the fact
that he's not very
much like a vampire.
He's more of a superhero
who says he's a vampire.
OK, so next, number of romantic
interest greater than two.
So if they have more than
two romantic interest,
they're a vampire.
And otherwise,
they're not a vampire.
So which ones would
that get wrong?
Hm?
AUDIENCE: 3 and 10.
PROFESSOR: Just 3
and 10, that's right.
Because Circe had Odysseus.
She had Telemachus.
Actually, she had that guy
she turned into a woodpecker.
She had that other guy
who was a sea god who
caused her to turn Scylla
into the nine-headed thing,
and probably at least
one other person.
So Circe it gets wrong.
And it also gets Edward Cullen
wrong because he only has one.
So 3 and 10.
You can tell I thought
about this problem
when I was writing it up.
I wrote this one.
All right, number of romantic
interest greater than four.
So it's a little bit
different this time.
Now you have to have at least
four romantic interests--
or actually, greater
than four, but there
are none that are exactly four--
to be classified as a vampire.
Which ones do you think
it's going to get wrong?
AUDIENCE: 3, 4, 10.
PROFESSOR: Yup, it is going
to get 3, 4, and 10 wrong.
Because now, you
run into the fact
that Saya has that blond
[INAUDIBLE] guy, Haji, and Kai.
So the last of the positive
ones-- because I claim I
can derive all the negative
ones if you guys give me
the positive ones.
The last of the positive ones
is everybody's a vampire.
Who does that get wrong?
AUDIENCE: 8, 9, 10.
PROFESSOR: Yes, OK.
Now, I can derive
all the negative ones
from this without a sweat.
Evil equals no-- well,
it's 1, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10
without looking at the chart.
Raise your hand if you see
why it's 1, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10
without looking at the chart.
Raise your hand if you don't.
Nobody, OK-- wait.
One hand.
OK, I saw another one
back there too later.
They were just more tentative.
OK, it's the complement
of A because A is
evil equals yes is a vampire.
It gets 2, 3, 4, and 5 wrong.
So therefore, evil equals no
is a vampire is guaranteed
to get all the opposite ones.
AUDIENCE: Oh, we could
have looked at that too?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
we're looking here,
but we're not looking
at the big chart there.
AUDIENCE: You can look at any?
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
If you can't look at
anything, then you're
screwed-- unless not only are
you as hardcore as this guy,
but you've also
memorized the numbers.
All right, so emo equals no is
going to be 2, 3, 4, 5, 8, 10.
Transforms equals no
is 1, 2, 6, 7, 9, 10.
Sparkle equals no is 3, 9, 10.
Romantic interest less than two
is everything except 3 and 10--
1, 2, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
1, 2, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
And then finally, everything but
8, 9, and 10, so 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7.
All right, so when
we started off,
we know what
everything gets wrong.
I then make a bold
claim, because there
are n of these, which is 14.
I make the claim that
there are only six
that, in your wildest dreams,
you would ever possibly
even consider using ever.
And the rest, you
would never, ever use.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I just have
a question about the number
of romantic interests.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: You negated it without
an equals on either side.
PROFESSOR: That's true.
That works only because
there are [INAUDIBLE] 2 or 4.
But it should have been negated
with a less than or equal.
I'm copying off of the quiz.
But yes.
I noticed that this morning
when I was putting myself
through my pace.
I'm like, there's not a
less than or equal to.
Wait a minute.
And then, oh, wait.
It doesn't have any 2's or 4's.
Actually, I don't
remember writing them all
as 5's and 3's.
It's possible that somebody
else in the post-editing process
changed them all to be
about the same number,
and then changed the
less than or equal tos
to be less confusing.
It's possible I had Circe
at 4, and there was an equal
to somewhere.
And they were like, forget it.
Because I can't think of
the fifth romantic interest
for her.
So yes, normally, you
would have to negate it
with an equal to sign,
but there happened
to not be any things that
are equal to 4 or 2 here.
So they get away
with it this time.
But it's good practice.
So I'm claiming that
in our wildest dreams,
we'd only ever want to
use six of these ever.
And the other eight, forget it.
So let's see.
I will call on people at random
to-- the first people obviously
are getting it really
easy-- to tell me
which of these you think that
you might ever want to use.
Give me one you might
ever want to use.
AUDIENCE: E.
PROFESSOR: Why, E?
Of course.
That's the best one.
Yes, that's one that you
might ever want to use.
I'll circle the ones that
you might ever want to use.
E-- it only gets 3 and 10 wrong.
That's amazing.
It's like the best
class of [INAUDIBLE].
OK, so give me another one
that you might ever want to us.
AUDIENCE: F.
PROFESSOR: F. Let's see.
F-- F is great.
It only gets three wrong.
Do people agree that you
would ever want to use F?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: Everyone's saying no.
Why not?
AUDIENCE: It's like
E, except worse.
PROFESSOR: It's like
It's guaranteed at
every step, no matter
what the weights are, to
have a worse accuracy than E.
It is definitely good.
If E wasn't around, it would
be one of our best classifiers
of all.
But actually, F is
not one of the six.
This is why I had them write on
the test that there were six,
because people might
not have found all six.
Because people who did
figure out not to include F
might not have figured out
to include some of the ones
you want to include.
So--
AUDIENCE: I don't understand
why you can't use F.
PROFESSOR: Why you
can't use F, OK.
So we start off with 1/10
weight for all our data points.
But let's say during
our time of boosting
that all ten of the data points
have now different weights.
So we'll call whatever
the weight of 3
is, which you're going
to get wrong-- you want
to minimize the error, right?
So that weight of 3, which goes
into the error of the E, is x.
The weight of 10 can be y.
So if you're thinking
of choosing 3,
you know you're-- oh, sorry.
If you're thinking of choosing
E, your error is x plus y.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
PROFESSOR: If you're
thinking of choosing F,
your error is x plus y plus
z, where z is the error of 4.
And since you're never going
to have a negative weight,
x plus y plus z is always
greater than x plus y.
AUDIENCE: You can't
choose something
without the 3 and the 10 anymore
because you already chose E.
PROFESSOR: That's-- yes, you
would probably choose something
that didn't get the
three and the ten wrong.
But you would certainly
never choose F ever
because it's always worse than
E. In fact, this is exactly
the process that will allow
you to find the correct six.
And by "will," I mean "can."
And by "can," I mean, let's
see if you guys get it.
Give me another one of the
six that you might keep.
AUDIENCE: K.
PROFESSOR: K is the
claim-- sparkly.
K, I'm going to say will
lose for the same reason
as F. It's 3, 9, and 10.
It's essentially
similar to 3, 4, and 10.
So-- oh, by the
way, we should not
be only going for the ones
with the fewest incorrect.
You need to be going for ones
that do not have something
that is strictly better.
In this case, 3 and
10 wrong is strictly
better than getting
3, 9, and 10 wrong.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Oh, I was
going to say transform.
PROFESSOR: You were
You are going to be correct.
Transforms is one of the
ones we need, C. 3, 4, 5
and 8-- there's nothing
down here that gets fewer
than those wrong.
There's nothing that gets us
3, 4, 5 wrong, for instance.
Yeah, there's no way to get 3,
4 wrong without getting either
10 wrong, or 5 and 8 wrong.
AUDIENCE: So why
is the 8 like that?
PROFESSOR: What?
AUDIENCE: Why not G?
PROFESSOR: Why not G?
Why not?
Why not G?
Let's include G, too.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
We don't have to do it all?
PROFESSOR: We need six.
No, I just said give me
any, and someone gave me
the easiest one, E. Question?
AUDIENCE: B
PROFESSOR: Why not B?
B looks great.
I love B. Let's include
B. Does someone else want
to give another one that
they want to include?
AUDIENCE: A.
PROFESSOR: A. Why not A?
Sure.
I mean, it's hard
to see down here
because there might be
something better on the bottom.
But yeah, there's not.
So let's include A. Why not A?
I love A. A's great.
OK.
So that is now five.
There's one more that we need.
It's by far the
hardest one to find.
Find me one more that there's
nothing better than it.
There's nothing that
has a strict subset
of the same ones wrong.
AUDIENCE: Question.
PROFESSOR: What?
AUDIENCE: Sorry,
can we quickly--
why would you choose
A before we chose C?
PROFESSOR: OK, why
would you choose A
before you've chosen C?
Let's say 8 was a
real problem for you.
And you were just getting--
let's say that 3, 4 and 5,
they weren't that bad.
They weren't that bad.
OK, you got them wrong
here with transforms.
You chose C. But sometime later,
8 was just by far your issue.
All right?
3, 4, and 5, and 8-- 3, 4 and
5 are much smaller weights
than 8.
And then after you've got 3,
4, 5, and 8 wrong, 3, 4, and 5
were still not that bad.
And 8 still was a high number.
And then sometime later down the
line, you're looking at things.
And you're saying,
you know what?
I really don't want
to get 8 wrong again,
but I don't mind if I
get 3, 4 and 5 wrong.
Maybe I'll get it
wrong with 2, which
I've never gone wrong yet.
Actually, none of the ones
we've circled here get 2 wrong,
so it's probably not
that bad to get 2 wrong.
So that's why-- because
it doesn't get 8 wrong.
If A was 2, 3, 4, 5,
8, you'd never take it.
Do you see what I mean?
Oh, did someone
raise their hand?
Did someone find it?
AUDIENCE: I just
have a question.
You can use the same reasoning
for choosing K, right?
Because after E, we
could have chosen A
and said that 9 only
a little different--
PROFESSOR: But it's
strictly worse.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, sorry, I meant
[INAUDIBLE] E to 9 and 10,
and then we could have
chosen 3, 9, and 10, right?
Because--
PROFESSOR: But we chose to
use E. Because getting only 3,
10 wrong is better
than getting 3, 9,
and 10 wrong in any universe.
You pick.
You see what I mean?
It might not be that much worse.
It might be only a little
bit worse to choose K,
but it's always worse.
So it-- question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the right
one by reasoning [INAUDIBLE]
we need one that
doesn't have 3 in it.
Because right now,
[INAUDIBLE] get 3 wrong.
PROFESSOR: OK, that's
a pretty good insight.
What are you thinking about?
AUDIENCE: Well, I'm
trying to justify D.
PROFESSOR: You're
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: D is huge.
It gets more than
half of them wrong.
But you know what?
It gets 3 right.
You know what?
It gets 10 right.
And unlike our things that get
3 and 10 right, which is B,
it also gets 9 right.
D is the last classifier.
You got it.
It's hard to choose one that
has seven of them wrong,
but D is the last
one you might pick.
It turns out there's
nothing better than this
for classifying correctly those
annoying data points of Edward
Cullen and Squall, and also
Circe, who's not that annoying,
but she tends to be a problem
when romance is concerned.
So these are the six
that we might use.
We can now ignore
the rest of them
forever-- or at least until
someone reuses this problem
or something like that.
But we can ignore everything
except A, B, C, D, E,
G. In fact, why did
I even bring that up?
All the ones we want
are on the front.
I'll bring it back down.
Then I'll cross this off
with reckless abandon.
That even broke off
a piece of my chalk.
Now, these are the ones
that we're actually
thinking about using.
There is a chart
over here already
prepared to do some boosting
with these six classifiers,
all right?
So let's give it a try.
Now, remember, in
boosting, we always
try to choose whichever
classifier has the least
errors.
Is there a question?
AUDIENCE: Sorry, yeah.
Before we move on, can
you say again a little
more slowly what
exactly we were looking
for when we were
choosing our classifiers,
like something about the subset?
PROFESSOR: You generally
want to take classifiers.
So I'll tell you what let's
you cross off a classifier.
That may be a
better way to do it.
You can cross off a classifier
as useless if-- and by the way,
this is only useful if
you can do it faster
than just wasting your time
looking at all of them.
Because if you can't cross
off some of them as useless--
usually on the test,
they won't make you.
You can just waste
your time and have
14 instead of six possibilities
every step of the boosting.
But take a look at this--
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
Then see.
Do you have anything
here that has
a strict subset of these wrong?
Oh, look.
2, 3, 4, 5 is a strict subset.
This can be crossed off.
1, 2, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9-- anything
that's a strict subset?
Yes, 1, 6, 7, 9.
So it can be crossed off.
1, 2, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
Let's see.
1, 6, 7, 9 is a strict subset.
3, 9, 10.
3, 10 is a strict subset.
1, 6, 7, 9-- a strict subset.
3, 4, 5, 8 is a strict
subset, as is 2, 3, 4, 5.
1, 6, 7, 9 is a strict subset.
And up here, 3, 4, 10--
3, 10 is a strict subset.
But the others don't have
one, even 1, 2, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
In general, you
want to keep them.
You want to keep every
classifier you might use.
The only ones
you'll never use are
ones that there's something
else that's just better always
by having a strict
subset of them wrong.
Hopefully, that was more clear.
It's tricky.
Very few people realize--
we're brave enough
to take sparkly even when
it got seven things wrong.
So let's start
out some boosting.
This wasn't boosting.
This was setting yourself up.
But it was setting yourself
up with the knowledge
of how boosting works.
Less knowledge, less search.
Now we only have to
search six things.
Ah, I mean more knowledge, less
search, not less knowledge,
less search.
So we start off with
all weights being equal.
And since there's
ten data points,
all ten of the data
points are weighted 1/10.
OK, we're now weighting
all of them equally.
Since we're
weighting all of them
equally, when we want to
find the classifier that
gets the least
error, we just want
to find the one that gets
the fewest points wrong.
Which one is that?
That's our friend E, the
first one that people
realized was a good one.
So we're going to
choose classifier E.
What's our error?
It's just the sum of
the ones we get wrong.
So what's our error this time?
It's 1/5.
We got points 3 and 10 wrong.
They both have a weight of 1/10.
1/10 plus 1/10 is 1/5.
So I'll put 1/5, and alpha.
Alpha is sort of a vote that
will be used at the very end
to aggregate our classifier.
Alpha is 1/2 natural log of 1
minus the error over the error.
However, I have a
little trick for you.
It's not that impressive of a
trick, but it's a little fun.
So since error is 1/2--
sorry, not error-- alpha.
Alpha is 1/2 natural log of
1 minus error over error.
If error is 1/x, then alpha is
1/2 natural log of x minus 1.
That just follows from the math.
It's a little shortcut.
If error is in the
form of 1/x, then it's
just 1/2 natural
log of x minus 1,
which means since this is in
the form of 1/5, everyone,
alpha is?
1/2 ln 4.
OK, 1/2 ln 4.
So now we come to
the part in boosting
that many people consider
the hardest part,
and I'm going to show you
how to do it more easily.
This is that part
where we try to make
all the ones we got right, we
change their weights to be 1/2.
And all of the
ones we got wrong,
we change their
weights to be 1/2.
Here is my automated process.
It's called the numerator
stays the same method.
Here's how it works.
Here's our ten data points.
Their current weight
is 1/10, all of them.
We're about to re-weight
them for the next step.
So you agree they're all 1/10?
They're equal, to start off.
So step one-- erase
the denominators.
Screw fractions.
I don't like them.
There's division,
multiplication.
It's a pain.
I just want to
add whole numbers.
That's what we're going to do.
So which ones do we get wrong?
3 and 10.
Circle those.
All right.
Add the numbers in the
circles and multiply by 2.
What does that give you?
4.
That's the new denominator.
AUDIENCE: Do you always
multiply by 2, or just--
PROFESSOR: You
always multiply by 2.
Add the numbers
not in the circles.
Multiply by 2.
What does that give you?
AUDIENCE: 16.
PROFESSOR: 16.
That's the new denominator.
The final, crucial step so that
we can do this again next round
is by far the most
mathematically
complicated thing
here because we
have to actually do
something with fractions,
but it's not too bad-- is
we then change everything
to be with the same denominator.
So the 1/4's become?
AUDIENCE: 4/16.
PROFESSOR: 4/16.
All right.
I can also uncircle
these for next-- ah.
I hit the that button.
All right.
New weights-- 1/16, 1/16, 4/16,
1/16, 1/16, 1/16, 1/16, 1/16,
4/16.
Note, the weights add up to 1.
The ones you got
wrong add up to 1/2.
right add up to 1/2.
You're happy.
So now that you get 4/16 of
an error for getting 3 wrong,
4/16 of an error for
getting 10 wrong,
take a look at these six.
I'm not going to
call on someone,
just whoever's good
at math and can
add these up more quickly--
just 3 and 10 count as 4.
All the others count as 1.
Add them up.
Tell me which
one's the lightest.
What did you say?
AUDIENCE: I'd go with B.
PROFESSOR: You'd go with
B. It doesn't get 3 wrong.
That sounds pretty good to me.
Does everyone else
like B as well?
I like it.
I mean, all of our ones that
don't get 3 wrong or 10 wrong,
we're only looking at B
and D. And D has seven.
B has four.
So B is the best.
B gets 4/16 wrong.
Does everyone see that?
Because even getting
one of 3 or 10 wrong
is as bad as all the ones
that B gets wrong because
of the new weights.
So cool.
Let's choose B. That's right.
And I sort of gave it away.
What's the error that B has?
It has four wrong, each
of which are worth 1/16.
The error is?
What?
4/16, or 1/4, whichever
is your favorite, which
means that the alpha is?
AUDIENCE: 1/2 ln 3.
PROFESSOR: 1/2 ln 3.
Bingo.
Final round.
OK, what did we get wrong?
We got 1, 6, 7, and 9 wrong.
Oh yeah, we can erase
the denominators.
All right.
What are the numbers in
the circles, summed up,
multiplied by 2?
AUDIENCE: 8.
PROFESSOR: That's 8-- 1/8.
And what about the numbers
not in the circle, summed up,
multiplied by 2?
AUDIENCE: 24.
PROFESSOR: That's
right-- 24, which
means I'm going
to have to change
all the numbers in the circle
to 3/24, except I guess I don't
because this is the last round.
But if I was going to
do another round-- let's
prepare in case we where,
change all of these to 3/24.
Besides, it makes it
easier to calculate
which one is the best possible
classifier because you can just
use the numerators and
sort of add them up.
So while I'm writing
that up, you guys
figure out which one
you like for classifier
and call it out to
me when I'm done.
3/24.
1/24.
4/24.
3/24.
1/24.
3/24-- wait.
I'm off by one here.
3, 1, 4--
AUDIENCE: It's because w1
is not assigned to anything.
So w2 is really w1.
PROFESSOR: Aha.
You're right.
w1 is not assigned to anything,
so w2 is really w1 Yeah?
AUDIENCE: There's an
extra 1/16 between w1, w2.
There's an extra 1/16.
PROFESSOR: Yes, that's true.
OK, well--
AUDIENCE: We get it.
PROFESSOR: You get it.
H, so what is the best H?
You get it because
it's right here.
See?
The process is so
foolproof, even a fool
like me can get it right while
they have the chart wrong.
All right, so what's
the best classifier?
AUDIENCE: C.
PROFESSOR: You say C. I say
that seems pretty reasonable.
It only gets 3,
4, 5, and 8 wrong.
Does anyone else get
a different answer?
AUDIENCE: A.
PROFESSOR: Someone else gets
A. I like A. Who said A?
A lot of people said A.
Well, let's figure it out.
So A gets 1, 5, 6, 7.
C gets 4, 5, 6, 7.
They're, in fact, equal.
Tie-break goes to
the lower letter
because that's what we said.
In fact, I didn't tell you,
but that's what we said.
Question?
AUDIENCE: So when we were
deciding which classifier
to use, can we only
look at the weights,
or do we also have to
look at the [INAUDIBLE]--
PROFESSOR: Ignore
all previous rounds.
The question is, do you only
look at the current weights
when determining a classifier?
Or do you look at the
previous rounds as well?
You have to ignore
the previous rounds.
Trust me.
They will be used
later in the vote.
But it's sort of like
tainting the jury a little bit
to use the previous rounds when
you're doing the current round.
Because you want to start
fresh with these new weights,
get a new classifier.
And then later, everyone
will get to make their vote.
So you only do it based
on the current weights.
AUDIENCE: We don't
take any consideration
if the last round's 6
was wrong or anything.
PROFESSOR: Nope, although the
weights take into consideration
is when it's wrong,
it's going to increase.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: Question?
AUDIENCE: Could
you theoretically
reuse a classifier?
PROFESSOR: The question is,
could you theoretically reuse
a classifier?
Answer-- you absolutely can.
When that happens, it
essentially gets extra weight
because you used it again.
But you can never, ever
use it twice in a row.
Here's why.
Let's say that we want to use--
which was the one we used last
over there?
B?
Let's say we wanted
to use B again.
What does it give us?
50-50.
If we wanted to use B and
then B-- 3, 6, 9, 12 wrong.
Always guaranteed
to give you 50-50,
which is the only
way that you can
be sure you'll never use it.
In fact, that's by design.
You could reuse it,
but not twice in a row.
It could be used later
on down the stream.
And it will be used.
Because if you do seven rounds,
one of them has to be reused.
It just gives more weight
to whichever one is reused.
But yes, A wins against C. C
was a perfectly good answer
as well.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Wait, can
you reuse [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: What?
AUDIENCE: Instead of A or C.
PROFESSOR: OK.
If you could reuse,
why doesn't he pick E?
E gets eight out of 24 wrong.
It's one worse than A and
C. That's the only reason.
Next step will probably
use A-- or sorry.
Well, next step,
we'll probably use E,
frankly-- although maybe not,
because we got 3 wrong on A.
But pretty soon, we
would use E again
because E's pretty awesome.
But anyway, here we used A.
And we said we got 7/24 wrong.
Oh, man, we can't use
my little shortcut.
So the answer, it has to be
17/7-- or 1/2 natural log
of 17/7.
So there we go.
Now, we have to ask, what is
the final classifier that we
created from all these things?
All we do is we sum up all
the classifiers we chose.
And we multiply them
times their weight, alpha.
So 1/2 ln 4 times
E, whether or not
E returns true, plus
1/2 ln 3 times B
plus 1/2 ln 17/7 times A, is
our final classifier, where
E returns a plus 1 if E thinks
it's a vampire, and a minus 1
if E think it's not.
Same for B and A, all right?
And then we take
the sign of this.
And I don't mean
sine and cosine.
I mean just, just is it
positive or negative?
OK?
So the question now on the exam
is, how many of the ten data
points do you get
right if we used this?
Let's give it a look see.
E is-- so we have romantic
interest greater than 2.
We have emo yes.
And we have evil yes.
So oh my gosh, logarithms,
they're sometimes annoying.
Do we have to
actually add them up?
I claim we don't.
Here's a nice special
case of having
three logarithms on the board.
One of two things is true.
Either one of those
three logarithms
is so large that it's
bigger than the other two
combined, in which case, if
that one returns a positive or a
negative, it's just positive
or negative because that one's
big.
Or one is not that
large, and in which
case, any two can
dominate the other one,
and so is just equivalent
to a majority vote.
So I claim we never have to add
them when there's only three.
You guys see what I mean?
Like, let's say one of them
was 1/2 log of a billion,
and the others were 1/2
log of 3 and 1/2 log of 4.
Obviously, whatever the
1/2 log of a billion
says, which is multiplied
by 1/2 log of a billion,
is it's just going to be that,
and the others will be ignored.
However, if it's not the
case that one of them
is larger than the
other two combined,
then it's a simple
vote between the three,
because any two can
out-vote the other one
if they work together.
And in this case, let's
see, 17/7 is not quite 3.
However, log of 4
is certainly not
better than log of
3 plus log of 17/7.
It's not even-- log
of 4 is equal to log
of 2 plus log of 2.
And these are both
bigger than log of 2.
That's rules of logs-- log
of 4 equals log of 2 squared,
and you can take the 2 out.
So these are not big
enough that one of them
is bigger than the
other two combined.
So it's just going
to be a simple vote.
So let's go through.
Dracula-- OK, he's got tons
of his little vampyrettes.
He's not emo, so
E gets it right.
He's not emo.
So that gets it wrong.
But he is evil.
That gets it right.
Two out of three vote that
he's a vampire-- correct.
Next.
Angel-- OK, well, he was
in a long running series.
He's got plenty of
romantic interests.
So that gets it right.
He's certainly emo.
That gets it right.
And even though he's not
evil, two out of three
says he's a vampire, so correct.
Next, Edward Cullen-- well,
Twilight, here we come.
Let's see.
He only has one
romantic interest,
so that gets it wrong.
OK.
He's emo, so that gets it right.
But he's not evil, so two wrong.
So Edward's not a
vampire according
to our final classifier.
But he is.
So we got one of the
data points wrong.
You guys see that?
Because two out of
three of our classifiers
here said that he
was not a vampire.
All right, let's see.
Saya-- well, she has more
than two romantic interests.
And she's emo.
So even though she's not
evil, we get it right.
OK?
Let's see.
Lestat-- he also has
may love interests,
is emo, and is not evil.
So you get it right.
OK, Bianca is evil with
many love interests.
Even though she's not emo, two
out of three, you get it right.
All right, Carmilla-- I'm
going to call her Karnstein--
is basically exactly
the same as Bianca
with the number of romantic
interests fixed the way it is.
So she will always do the
same thing that Bianca does.
It's why 6 and 7
always travel together.
So we get it right.
Sailor Moon is supposed
to be not a vampire.
So her number of love interests
say that she's not a vampire
because she only has one.
The fact that she's
not evil and not emo
says that actually, she's
perfectly not a vampire.
They all agree.
And that's correct.
Squall has only one
love interest, Rinoa.
And he's not evil, both of
which of say he's not a vampire.
But he is emo.
But two out of three
says he's not a vampire.
We get it correct.
And Circe, despite her
many romantic interests
which says she
might be a vampire,
is neither evil nor emo,
and is not a vampire.
So we got everything right
except Edward Cullen,
which perhaps says more about
Stephenie Meyers writing
than about our boosting.
All right, final
question-- Wesley Wyndham,
a fellow consultant, has noticed
a few correlations between some
of the classifiers you used.
He suggests using a new set
of weak classifiers consisting
of a pair of your classifiers
that are logically
anded and ored together.
For instance, two of
the new classifiers
would be emo equals yes or evil
equals yes, or sparkly equals
no and transforms equals yes.
So that would cut out Sailor
Moon from the transforms cloud.
He believes that you'll be able
to classify large vampire data
sets-- larger than
this one, anyway--
more quickly with fewer rounds
of boosting using his system.
Do you agree or
disagree with Wesley?
Explain your arguments.
So this was, you know, the
tough concept question.
Does anyone have just an
instinctual thing other
than like, oh, man, it's Wesley.
He must be wrong.
AUDIENCE: You'll
probably use fewer rounds
of boosting because you
have more classifiers.
But you'll have to search
through more classifiers.
PROFESSOR: Aha, that is
the rare full-point answer.
Very few people realize that
Wesley was partially right.
They either said something about
him being completely wrong,
which was wrong, or said
that he was completely right.
Yes, it will use fewer rounds
of boosting because of the fact
that you can-- essentially,
one of these boosting already
does is sort of gets
things to vote together
in an [INAUDIBLE] fashion.
So it will use
approximately half
the number of rounds
of boosting by being
able to combine into two.
But there's a lot
of ands and ors.
There's in fact
n choose 2, where
n is the number of vampires.
And since using half the
number of rounds but taking n
choose 2 time for each
round is not less time.
So that's exactly correct.
Not that many people got
full credit on that one
because sometimes, they were
seduced by Wesley's idea.
Or they were just
like, it's Wesley.
He's wrong-- or just
some other funny answer.
Any questions about boosting?
Question?
AUDIENCE: How do you know
how many rounds of boosting
to take?
PROFESSOR: The
question is, how do you
know how many rounds
of boosting to do?
The answer is--
so on the quiz, it
tells you that you have three.
In real life, you might
want to just kind of keep
it running until it converges.
That's one possibility--
keep it running
until it converges
to an answer, and it
doesn't do anything anymore.
Patrick has a little widget
on the 6.034 website, I think,
that lets you plunk
down some data points
and run boosting on them.
And you can see that
eventually, it converges.
The boosting converges to an
answer, and it doesn't change.
AUDIENCE: What converges?
PROFESSOR: Basically,
the-- not the classifiers
you picked, of course,
or the weights.
But what converges is
which ones of your data set
you get correct.
Because he does his in
two-dimensional space
rather than like this.
And he shows you the
lines that boosting
is drawing between
classification,
and colors things in green and
red or something like that.
And eventually, it converges
where the lines are
and which ones
it's getting right.
It generally converges to
getting everything correct.
And when that happens,
then you can stop.
But that's a good question.
And it's not always that
easy in the real world.
You have to sometimes just
say, this is enough for me.
I've given it n
number of rounds.
And that's much more the
number of classifiers,
so maybe it won't
get anything better.